brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com hey guys it is the
fourth of much today my name is Jessa
McDonald and you're tuned into games but
news here's the Alpha mention that
countdown clock on the middle gear solid
5 website wrapped up early this morning
and lo and behold no surprises here we
got a release date we also got a bunch
of information about different editions
of the game Konami revealed that the
console edition will arrive on sep
tember one but PC players will have to
wait an extra couple of weeks until sep
tember 15 they also unveiled the day one
and collector's edition the $60 day one
edition includes a physical map and a
bunch of DLC items including equipment
and an exclusive cardboard box for snake
if you're a die-hard fan you could pick
up the collector's edition although it
will run you ninety nine dollars that
includes a steelbook our
behind-the-scenes documentary and
trailers on blu-ray their physical map
and a half-scale replica of snakes
bionic arm you'll get all these physical
items in addition to even more DLC
ranging from new weapons and costumes to
three fancy cardboard boxes check out
the list of content in detail on
gamespot the new wolfenstein game is
coming at it set to be a prequel to the
new order it's called Wolfenstein the
old blood created by the new order dev
machine games the old blood will launch
on may five for 20 bucks and will be
available on xbox one ps4 and PC the
digital only title will feature a
two-part story set in 1946 right before
the end of their alternate history world
war 2 you once again step into the
heroic boots of PG blaskowitz and
venture through bavaria breaking into
Castle Wolfenstein and killing thousands
of Nazis across the city of Wolfsburg
with a bunch of new weapons if you want
all the story specifics you can find
them on
gamespot and finally nvidia had
themselves a press conference at GDC and
fears all the good stuff you probably
want to know about nvidia revealed titan
x what they're calling the world's most
advanced GPU the black and green card is
certainly super styling but it also
comes with some pest offering 12
gigabytes of ram and eight billion
transistors no pricing info is out just
yet but I'm assuming we can make an
educated guess that if we have to ask we
can't afford it nvidia also announced
their shield gaming console the android
TV based device is powered by Nvidia's
Tegra x1 superchip and is bundled with
one shield controller all that will run
you 200 bucks a bluetooth remote with
voice capability is also available the
shield console can do a bunch of things
download films music and games from the
Google Play Store stream games from your
existing PC to the device and also
cooked into Nvidia's Netflix tile new
game subscription service called the
nvidia grid where you can instantly
stream and play new triple a pc games
from nvidia servers to the device nvidia
claimant has twice the processing power
of the xbox 360 and six times more ram
the console will be launching with 50
android games for all the details and
the hands-on video preview be sure to
visit gamespot let me know down in the
colors if you like the look of nvidia
shield console and why or why not you
can head to gain start where we've got
news on razors VR headset and gone home
camp with console version that is it for
me today but i'll be back with a bunch
more news stories can you think
you are so the shoulder check back to be
done